foreign
let's go out to uh Raleigh North
Carolina and talk to Dan
the man what's up Dan
hey how are Easter outstanding brother I
don't see anything outstanding so man uh
what's happening
uh
again let me let me practice this by
saying I know I'm not the good guy here
uh I'm just trying to
you know figure out how to how to get my
life back
cool tell me what happened man
um I'm about a year ago I entered into
an affair with someone at work okay and
um blindsided my wife
and moved in
uh with another woman
and
for this last year
uh you know we found our ups and downs
um we've had some communication issues
and a lot going on
uh now uh well I guess not now but
ultimately uh she had a child uh it was
just a year over a year old
and I raised this child
to like my own and the
you know the father was in the picture
uh he's a he's a good dad he's there
um but it's
it's caused some issues in the fact that
around Christmas time uh we decided
that we wanted to do on Christmas
um because I saw how having two separate
thanksgivings you know it just and
devastated uh
and devastated the mom
and uh ultimately he he never left he
sort of just moved in and then we made
it official so it was me
uh I guess my girlfriend and
the father of her child Under One Roof
along with the toddler and
there was always you know some friction
there anything he was a nice guy
um but you know it was just a very weird
dynamic yeah you think
yes
like there had to like there had to have
been a point when you were thinking like
just sitting on on the toilet just
scroll on Instagram you were like this
probably is not a great idea
yeah well you know I'm I'm not big into
social media I stay away from that well
good God Almighty you know what I'm
trying to say like at some point you're
like this is a terrible idea so was your
wife I mean I'm sorry it was your
girlfriend
I mean were you all like a like a
throuple we all all in this together or
was she dating two guys or uh she was
she was just dating me but no way no way
of course she hooked back up with him no
no
it was it was very weird but it wasn't
it wasn't like that
like that he had a lot of debt and he
didn't have anywhere else to go really
and she didn't want to take time away
uh from him with his child
or at least that was her thought process
there was no thinking going on at all
but okay so bring me to bring me to now
yeah yeah
um so let me let me just let me just
recap so
you're married how long were you married
uh it was going to be eight years in
August of last year so it's seven years
you you bailed and moved in with
somebody
um that at work so you you had met
somebody at work you fell in love you
you choose your girlfriend you moved out
on your wife just blindsided your wife
moved out did you divorce your wife or
did you all just get separated uh we are
currently separated okay so you're not
officially divorced
correct why haven't y'all why hasn't she
filed on you are you on her
well we're doing uh a simple divorce so
we've been a year apart and then
uh it should be a pretty simple process
for that because no one's trying to get
any anything from anyone oh I forgot
North Carolina's got some of the
stupidest rules when it comes to that
crap
um so uh
laughs so then you move in with this
woman and you have normal relationship
issues and probably some good times and
probably some what in the world times
and she's got a one-year-old and then at
Thanksgiving
um there's two different thanksgivings
and then y'all are like let's not do
that at Christmas and so
baby daddy comes to stay for Christmas
and then just like Moves In
yes
so then what that obviously you know
cuts down on the intimacy Factor no no
it doesn't
yes it does believe it or not no way no
way and
um
you know
I feel like I
have done everything I possibly could to
to make it work
um I I basically changed
you know I
everything I didn't do before I'm I
tried to emphasize
me doing and it was an extremely
rewarding experience
but you know every every day I woke up I
I knew that if I had tried that hard
with my wife
you know I wouldn't be in that position
why'd you leave your wife
um
well
and I say that at the time because I
have you know hindsight
have me just being a
um why don't you leave your wife
she
um said you know she wasn't sure if she
was really a Believer anymore
and
it
it's actually wasn't really sure if she
wanted to have kids
anymore okay
I'm glad
I mean that's what I told myself at the
time but
it was really
you know
I just I didn't feel like I mattered
and she was she was locked and
um sorry all right all right man you're
right shake your breath talk directly
into your phone for me I want to make
sure we get all this
I just didn't feel like I'm at it it
didn't matter if I
it was there or not
um I mean she she had it
she's a thousand times smarter than me
by the way obviously
um so that's what I told myself
so this happens over time
and the whole time or at some point some
point during this time
there's a co-worker that's hilarious
kind of pretty at first and gets more
pretty over time and
do what
like you wouldn't believe John yeah last
at your jokes
um put your hand on your shoulder when
she's telling you a funny thing or on
your forearm just little gentle things
like that and
you suddenly for the first time in a
long time feel that terrifying feeling
of alive again
yes sir
and then you can look back at your home
life and come up with any number of
reasons why this is the right thing and
what you've been doing for the last
seven or eight years is the wrong thing
yes
um yes
so you've been you've burned through a
year you know that's a mess
and now what
so a few weeks ago or a couple weeks ago
I
as she asked me uh my girlfriend texts
me hey do you want to meet
um at a place uh Gary it's a local town
over here
um and I say sure
and I I go over there
and we go into the Whole Foods to get
some snacks you know it's not unusual
for her to do this kind of thing where
we just have a little picnic
and we go over because they have a
little play area
where kids can play she takes me over
there and she says
I can't do this
um because our lease was coming up uh it
was it's expiring
so I can't move to a new home with you
uh
uh I can't live with two men I'm not
married to anymore and I can't take time
away
from the father of my child's
like I can't take time away with from
him and his son
so
that's uh
I uh
so you got dumped
I I don't and uh you know in a split
second I lost uh
everything I had yeah and uh
was blindsided and obviously there's
some kind of
larger humor here for everything I did
to someone yeah
I think Alanis Morissette is saying
about that right yeah
and uh so how can I how can I help you
right now man
I know you're hurting yeah I woke up
uh the next day at a rest homes and not
a rest home like a rest of the area I'm
not that old
rest area and I've never felt more alone
in my life
at a single time
and
I just didn't know what to do
so
I uh
I texted my wife I was like hey
here's what happened
um you can track me now on Google Maps
just uh keep an eye on me if you don't
mind
and then I asked if she wanted to just
meet up the talk later and she said sure
she she responded immediately
and uh shoes you know since in fact
she's just been an absolute rock for me
again
and
I don't know what to do
not just one of my life backs
whatever that looks like I want to be
okay
I think you can be okay
the life you had is over
and the longer you try to pretend the
last year didn't happen
the longer you try to avoid the fact
that you ripped some woman's heart out
the longer you try to not feel the fact
that your heart just got ripped out
that's a recipe for disaster down the
road
it's grief it's heartache it's shame
it's all that
and if you try to run past this and try
to over like end around this thing it
will haunt you
physiologically this is not just woo-woo
this is neuroscience it will haunt you
there is no going there is no going back
the beautiful thing is you can build
something else
there we go I sort of just buried myself
in my work and you know pouring myself
into
my girlfriend and this child
and you know I don't I don't want to
bury anything that stunts good
but
I this is just me and you're a grown-up
and your wife's a grown up
um
I'm talking to you as though you and
you're one of my close Buddies
I would tell you she doesn't
you don't get to just run back to her
and say my bad
now she may love you forever and be
willing to take you right back and all
that I don't even know if that's what
you're asking
um
okay
but I think you're going to be
responsible for
well
then you'll be responsible for a couple
different things number one
you've got to be responsible for your
healing and of course you're worthy of
being loved but right now you may not be
worthy of dating or being married to
and you may have a lot of work to do on
becoming marriage material becoming
romantically involved material has
nothing to do with your lovability in
your intrinsic worth as a person
do you see the difference there
yeah
if your wife was my close friend I would
tell her to be very very careful with
you
because you just had your heart broken
and You're vulnerable
absolutely
and
uh
I mean even looking back a couple weeks
ago I just feel like it was so selfish
of me to contact her at all no I mean it
was but you're also it's selfish to I
mean I guess it's technically selfish if
you're drowning to scream at somebody
you know
in the Lifeguard stand and say help me I
guess that's inherently selfish because
I don't want to drown but that's the
right thing to do
I think that's a good signal to you that
you've got to be about the business of
making friends
and getting some community in your life
and getting some accountability and some
men in your life that you trust that can
speak into your life
and possibly not possibly a hundred
percent before the day's over calling
and getting a counselor or a therapist
in your community
and I know there's some great ones in
Raleigh North Carolina
a friend of mine
had spoken
about who's not
a pastor
I I called him too and I met with him
last week and I'm meeting with him
uh in a few hours today so okay but
listen he doesn't get to be your
therapist he gets to be your friend
yeah he gets to refer you and you have
to be very intentional about asking him
I need referrals to professionals
um because I need you as my friend
what does that mean he needs to hold the
right to call you really stupid like
what you're doing is dumb or what you're
doing isn't healthy or get off the couch
we're going running or whatever we're
going to the gym right now he needs to
preserve that
and you need to go do hard therapy with
a professional therapist and there's a
powerful different difference
okay yeah
and you've got to hear me there is no
going back you don't get your old life
back it's over
it's over
the the mission before you is what are
you going to build
um what are you going to build next what
are you going to build moving forward
and it's gonna take a long time
that's not not something to be scared of
in fact it's the opposite it's something
to settle into it's gonna be a bunch of
tiny decisions that you make every
single day they're going to start to
create new habits they're going to start
to create new ways you see the world and
experience the world and think about the
world and the world thinks and
experiences you
and then you're going to make some major
changes
and I think
um
if you haven't already I think there's
something very important not for
something back
not for an Roi
but you may have gotten a glimpse now
and I only think it's a glimpse because
you were playing house with somebody for
a year and also with her other boyfriend
who she had a kid by that whole weird
thing
you got a glimpse
of the pain your wife experienced just a
glimpse
but I think there's something about
getting down on your knees in front of
her and saying
how gut-wrenchingly sorry you are
and maybe this divorce continues on
maybe I'll find reconciliation down the
road that's not a today conversation
today conversation is
I need to take a knee before the woman I
promised my life to and let her know
I hurt you so bad I'm sorry
and my mission in life is to become a
man that will never hurt somebody like
that ever ever ever again myself
included
I think you can do that
I wouldn't do this show if I didn't
believe in that sort of restoration but
it's gonna be tough you're gonna be very
vulnerable and very honest and most
importantly you have to do stuff you've
never done before
in terms of telling the truth and
letting your needs be heard
and I'm not this isn't the playroom I'm
not gonna beat you up on the show I know
you're hurting bad right now
I know you're hurting bad
don't give up on you man
uh we'll be with you every step of the
way hang on the line and almost in your
coffee on your past change your future
um stay on the line Jenna we'll send
that to you just my treat if I can help
you anyway brother holler at me okay
but today when you go talk to your body
say I need you to be my friend moving
forward I need some references because I
got some hard work I got to do a hit
and then call that wife yours and sit
down
take a knee say
sorry
that level of vulnerability that's
that's the soil that we'll start
planting new seeds in